In order to make your language learning a lot more fun,...
...then you should focus on the things that interest you the most.
If you want to learn the language to learn more about the culture,...
...then you should be watching films,...
...you should be reading and enjoying those things that are available.
It's also important to reward yourself for the learning that you're doing,...
...so make sure that you give yourself little treats...
...and maybe even plan a holiday or trip to...
...the country where they speak the language...
...so you can actually see how much progress you've made since you started learning...
...and how far you could still come in a similar amount of time.